pour des dizaines de milliers de jeunes
américains à une heure où de new york un
festival de pop music interdit un
festival de rock 100 rock s'est
transformée en un grand festival de la
drogue du retour à la vie primitive
tournant résolument le dos à la
civilisation bâti par les aînés tous ces
jeunes ont dû se contenter d'orchestre
improviser sans haut parleur
l'explication du phénomène depuis le
festival de woodstock l'an dernier cinq
cent mille personnes une ambiance
délirante des recettes énormes
organisateurs et jeunesse rêve d'en
organiser d'autres
mais depuis la maison blanche jusqu'aux
autorités locales on redoute désormais
ce genre de rassemblement explosif
parfois de la jeunesse la semaine
dernière à chicago un petit festival pop
s'est terminée en émeutes avec une
cinquantaine de blessés
du coup dans cette petite ville du
connecticut les autorités locales au
dernier moment ont interdit ce festival
met près de vingt mille jeunes étaient
déjà installés sur le terrain on a bien
bloqué les routes mais ils continuaient
à arriver
impossible de les déloger du coup on a
toléré
le rassemblement à la condition qu'il
n'y ait pas de musique perd cette sorte
de réserve ils ont convergé depuis tous
les points des états unis en auto stop
avec le sac à dos la tente quelques
dollars en poche
tous ont revêtu de ce que l'on pourrait
appeler le même uniforme chevelus et
barbus débraillé bariolé de
soutien-gorge banny parfois dans le plus
simple appareil
sur cette étrange camping flotte une
odeur entêtante de mari wayne faught de
musique on s'est en effet abattue sur la
drogue la drogue on la vend partout
librement peuchère d'ailleurs le pote la
marijuana la sig laisse jamais encore
aux états unis on avait vu la drogue se
vendre comme cela sous la seule
surveillance d'hélicoptères qui ronronne
dans le ciel la communauté s'organise
par tech tour et se proclame et se
démontre pacifique la télévision des
formes toujours notre image viennent
nous dire les jeunes il faut d'ajouter
que la majorité des américains depuis
quelques jours aperçoit chaque soir ce
spectacle à télévision et plein d'effroi
devant sa jeunesse parfois même plein de
n 7 n s'explique
pendant des années la mairie qu'a vécu
sous le règne de l'enfant roi
les parents travaillant dur leur
préparer la terre promise
le rêve américain et voilà maintenant
que cette jeunesse une partie de cette
jeunesse rejette ce rêve
certains adultes ne leur pardonne pas il
arrive qu'un de ces jeunes rentrent en
dha spectacle comme celui là le soir sur
une route déserte au soin froidement une
balle dans la tête
le prix d'un rêve le prix d'une
contestation jugé par beaucoup comme une
trahison de la mairie connecticut
informations première